wir zeigen Ihnen hierbei Bild den
mutigsten Kioskbesitzer Deutschlands
heute das ist Dolan Khan aus Frankfurt
am Main ein Schrecken sitzt diese Mann
schon noch in den Knochen nach all dem
Wasser erlebt hat er hat drei maskierte
und bewaffnete Räuber in die Flucht
geschlagen mit einem alten Barhocker und
das alles gefilmt auch noch mit seiner
Überwachungskamera
0:35 Uhr Montag Nacht drei maskierte
Männer stürmen den kankiosk in der
Frankfurter Fahrgasse mit vorgehaltener
Waffe fordern sie Geld Dolan Kahn der
Kiosk Betreiber wehrt sich mit einem
Barhocker schlägt er die Räuber in die
Flucht
ja der Anfang Maske und die kommen dann
mit Pistole und hat gesagt gib mal Geld
dann habe ich nicht Stühle genommen und
habe ich die gleiche geschlagen habe ich
die Stunde genommen
Bilder der Überwachungskamera zeigen wie
kann vom Gangster Trio überfallen wird
ein weiterer Mann hinter dem
verkaufsriesen hilft es ist Stammgast
Verdi ajabi er hält den pistolen-mann
fest Dolan greift zum Barhocker auf dem
er sich sonst während langer
Nachtschichten ausruht Roms die
räubertürmen Barhocker gegen Pistole
Holz gegen Eisen laut Polizei Türmen die
Männer im Kleinwagen mit geklautem
Kennzeichen nach Bildinfos ein weißer VW
Golf mit Offenbacher Kennzeichen die
Kriminalpolizei ermittelt wegen schwerer
räuberische Erpressung und sucht nach
Zeugen ja ich habe ein bisschen Angst
aber ich das Ganze aber trotzdem ich
will irgendwas machen die egal wie viel
mal kommen
zwei der Täter sind männlich ca 20 bis
30 Jahre alt 1,60 m bis 1,70 m groß
normale Statue der dritte Täter ist
männlich ca 1,70 m groß mit kräftiger
Statur
[Musik]
die Fahndung läuft also nach diesen
Tätern
[Musik]